hello everyone and welcome to today's
broadcast tracking antibiotic resistance
across space and time presented by Sean
Conlon associate investigator microbial
genomics section National Institutes of
Health I'm Alexis Krause of lab birds
and I will be our moderator for today's
event we are delighted to bring in this
educational web seminar presented by
laberd's laborat is the leading
scientific social networking website and
producer of educational virtual events
and webinars before we begin I would
like to remind everyone that the spend
is interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want and I need time
you want during the presentation just
click on the ask a question box located
on the far left your screen and type
your questions into the drop-down box
that appears on the screen our speaker
will respond to your questions via email
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation please click on the ask
a question box to let us know that
you're having a problem this
presentation is educational and thus
offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located in the top right
corner of the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain your
credits please join me in welcoming dr.
Conlon I will now turn the presentation
over to him hi so as Alexis pointed out
today I'm going to be talking to you
about tracking antibiotic resistance
across space and time our lab does a lot
of genomics we do a lot of genome
sequencing microbiome sequencing and
things like that and metagenomics today
I'm pretty much gonna be talking about
using genome sequencing in a sort of
forensics or way to track down
relationships between bacteria with
across space and time to give you a
little bit of a signpost as to where
we're gonna be going today I'm gonna
give you a little bit of background on
what we're really interested in in this
talk which is carbon pen and resistance
and a lot of our work stems from work at
the NIH Clinical Center
we're starting with a cluster of
Klebsiella pneumoniae infections for
2011 going through to follow up on two
patients from that cluster and then
we're gonna talk about switched gears a
little bit and talk about study we did
on organisms that are in the hospital
plumbing system and some of the
environmental areas of the hospital when
these are all going to be tied together
in terms of either tramping things as
they change across time things like
plasma dynamics and isolates or as they
relate to space or surfaces and patients
so the the gene that we're really
interested in for most of our studies is
the current pet amaze gene there's a
couple of different variants of it you
may have heard of the club seal and
ammonia carb enemies KP Singh is the one
that we're interested in but others that
you may have heard of include things
like MDM which is the add new telling
potato it'll act amazed or ox of 48 and
as you can see from this slightly dated
America map of the United States from
the CDC is pretty much found all over
the United States and and so that's one
of the reasons that we're really
interested in it because it is it's
pretty widespread and and if you looked
at a world map you would see that these
genes have slightly differing propensity
across different parts of the world
so the matelo are the beta lactamase
cleaves this lactam ring that you'll see
in the upper left hand corner of kind of
a stereotypical kind of been like 2 min
of a otic classic-car up enemies drugs
are things like any pen in the mirror
and image in the lower corner and one of
the features of the k pc gene is that it
is on plasmids typically I can also
occur in the chromosome but it's very
often in a plasmid inside the context of
a transpose well element and so mobility
is a real issue for this with this gene
so a lot of times what we're interested
in and if you think about classic
studies of how bacteria are transmitted
from person to person you sort of think
about the scenario that you see in
Frederick which is you know person a
person transmits something to person B
and it might be some bacteria and and
that that little circle inside is a
plasmid and and so this would be a
fairly straightforward thing to track
down you might be in a lab culturing
bacteria and finding out if two people
had the same bacteria with the same n
about except abilities but there's also
this scenario where either within a
patient or within some other niche or
environment the plasma that you're
interested in what the KTBC gene has
actually been transmitted in some way to
another host and then that host is then
transmitted to a different person and so
now it's it's sort of like I like to
liken to the sort of cup and ball game
that you see sometimes magicians tune
where they they have a cup and they're
moving a ball and around underneath
things now the the ball you're trying to
follow the plasmid has moved to a
different house and the same thing can
happen on surfaces as I mentioned
something can be transmitted to a
surface or a reservoir in the
environment where you can have these
same sorts of interactions going on in
epidemiologists are interested in
separating all of this out from this
last case which is is transmissions
within the hospital compared to somebody
walking in off the street with an
organism
so those of Comilla transmissions are
very worrisome for hospitals you're
trying to prevent that and and that's
how you prevent outbreaks one of the
ways in which you've read outbreaks that
a hospital or clusters and infections
and the hospital is preventing these
sort of nosocomial or within Hospital
transmissions so we've done quite a lot
of work in the lab on this this cluster
of carp nm resistant organisms from 2011
and this is beautiful work done by Evans
Nick King who's and it was in the lab at
the time and he he basically elucidated
this transmission network where a single
index patient through three separate
transmissions started this cascade of
transmission events and in total there
were 19 patients with 18 transmissions
that the index plus lots of
transmissions education and so and in
this work that he did he's both
epidemiological data which is indicated
by the inferences that are read
and genomic single nucleotide variant
data which is until a charism you
couldn't have created this transmission
map with either piece of data alone and
what we determined is that it's a clonal
transmission of sequence type 258
Klebsiella pneumoniae and we figured out
just from this is all done with four or
five for sequencing at the time with
scaffolding to known references we were
able to figure out there are three
plasmids ax k k PQ IL which is a known k
pc carrying plasmid p AC 1 v 4 which is
a small sort of accessory plasma and PK
p and 498 which is very large other
large plasma we followed up this study
because this was a fairly important
outbreak for our clinical center we
followed this up with us OSI and so this
is the this is the actual the three
Pleasants kind of shown all together
with the the organism and so we followed
this up and i'm not going to talk about
this too much but i kind of wanted to
give you a flavor for some of the things
that we do with a paper in 2014 where we
looked at all of the other k pc positive
organisms that cropped up following that
outbreak we were trying to make sure
that there weren't any additional
transmissions that miss plasmids and
this is all done with a long read
sequencing I've shown the PacBio on
instrument and so we were able to
elucidate lots and lots of different
plasmids each of these organisms has at
least one KP C+ plasmid sometimes
multiple sometimes multiple copies of KP
c on a single plasmid and so you can see
sort of the diversity of plasmids and
things like that that you can get out of
these organisms and we really learned a
lot from this and and found a couple of
classes of plasmids including a plasma
that we refer to kind of in shorthand as
the ink and plasma compatibility and
type plasmid that's widespread and we
found it in subsequent studies and I
think you'll see that a little bit later
so moving on to sort of the first part
of my talk on now that we threw in the
background is this long term
colonization of patients from the 2011
study so we followed up on on two of the
patients who remain colonized long term
with KP c positive organic
and so in a time span over over the
course of years we received samples and
these are these are samples of involving
patient care so these weren't patients
who are necessarily we weren't sampling
these for scientific reasons they were
taken as part of their routine care as
part of culturing and so we sort of get
what we get as far as timing and and
what organisms we were able to ask for
tame and this is a timeline of those two
patients patients 15 and 16 and it's a
relatively busy slide I realize but I
just wanted to give you a little bit of
a flavor a sort of frequency of
samplings and things like that with all
of those red diamonds being cultures
that were negative for kpc positive
organisms and the filled plusses or the
they're filled circles the the the fills
symbols are actually isolates we
sequenced and the rest are positives so
I'm going to be talking about the
isolates that we sequenced from these
two different patients and they tell two
different stories about what happens
when you start with remember we're
starting with a clonal outbreak so we
know what the original organism was and
what happens to it so so this is patient
15 and as I said a day one sort of at
the first culture that we have for a
KPCC positive organism you're gonna see
an organism that looks very much like
what I showed you for the outbreak so
it's three plasmids important one being
the PK p q il+ and we also have some
markers that are on these genes too that
are on the P AC 154 and three that are
on the p KP and 498 and so what you're
gonna see is over time as we now switch
to the second isolate there's not very
much has changed those markers are all
still there by PCR and then by
sequencing we still see the same
configuration of plasmids and this is
437 days later you see something
different a day 642 this is the third
isolate we sequence and if you're if
you're keen you're sort of looking
carefully at that diagram you'll see
that the plasmids have changed a little
bit I'll cycle back and forth real quick
and you'll see in a minute why that is
and you'll see that some of the bands in
the PCR s have changed
and so we we've we've done a lot of
sequencing on these organisms and the
sequencing told us a lot but I just
wanted to point out that we always try
to also verify these sorts of things
with PCR so that's why you sort of see
the side by side PCR assays to kind of
verify that we really are seeing the
changes and recombinations and whatnot
that we see by sequencing because we're
always a little concerned about you know
possibility of things like sequencing or
assembly errors so what's happening in
the case of these two plasmids is shown
here so in the kind of banded lots of
colors
left half of your screen there's two
plasmids you'll see PA c15 for labeled
up at the top and you'll see PK pn 498
kind of around the the left-hand side
and this is a circus plot showing the
bands are showing you recombination
events that we were able to detect by
sequencing the most interesting one
being this PK pn 821 that is the kind of
recombinant plasmid that you saw in two
colors in the previous slide and what
you'll see is that this very small
plasmid has had a recombination event
where it's picked up a bunch of genes
the that are shown by the kind of orange
colored band for antibiotic resistance
those have been inserted into the middle
of and disrupted a coalesce and gene and
or a toxin gene in the middle of that
abc15 for plasmid and there's been a
small duplication in addition the
remaining piece of that large PK pn 498
plasmid that shown by the purple band as
excised out and formed its own new
smaller plasmid called PK pn ffff you'll
notice if you look carefully at those
colors that those the points where those
circo's bands are connecting the two
plasmids there's some little brown
slashes those are there's a transpose mo
element so that all the trans poseable
elements and resolved base that are
colored brown so this is probably these
these breaks are probably occurring on
or around or being mediated by
transposons so we thought this is pretty
interesting that
that this these two plasmids have
recombined chunks of that larger plasma
they've now been lost including the iron
acquisition sort of region which is
marked by that FEC D gene and that's
actually one if ice were to go back to
the previous slide that's one of the
markers that we're looking at so this is
the the PK pql plasmid which is the
important plasmid those four track and
didn't really change for this particular
isolate but um these recombination
events show you sort of how dynamic
plasmids can be so for patients 16 we
had a pretty different situation and
what we have here is again starting on
all the way to your left is sort of
original isolate and what I've kind of
got here is diagrams of the plasmids
that are contained by each organism that
we've isolated so there's a there's two
blue eye slits which rst 258 Klebsiella
pneumoniae x' and then we later isolated
two different s T 37 Klebsiella
pneumoniae x' and then we isolated at
the very end the S T 258 again and we'll
talk about that in a minute what that
means and then there was also in there
an e coli that was isolated containing
this plasmid there's some interesting
features here again if you're paying
attention you may remember that I told
you that all of the all of the outbreak
guys let's have three plasmids but the
organism that's all the way to the left
actually is showing you five that's
because this I so we went back and look
in the four five four data we found that
there really were two very small cryptic
plasmids they're the two that are sort
of at the bottom but it really only
found in this ISIL we don't know where
they came from but they are they are
additional to that to that organism but
you'll notice if you look over to the
the second kind of cyan colored
Klebsiella pneumoniae s 237 one of those
little extra plasmids actually pops up
again it's we don't we don't have one of
the things I always point out about this
slide is that there's probably a very
complicated network or plasmid
transmission and recombination events
going on here and we only see a few
nodes out of this in this diagram
because of what we seek
we had available sequence and so you can
kind of as you look over this see how
some plasmids have persisted over time
you can see one interesting point is
that that blue plasmid at the top starts
out at the far left as sort of the
full-length plasma that is PK PN 498
there's a deletion insertion event the
next time that we seen that that plasmid
and then the final time we see that
organism which is all the way to their
right the blue organism it's gone and
I'm gonna talk about that in a bit in a
minute because it's it's a recurring
theme right now what I'd like to talk to
you a little bit about is this plasmid
they're red ones so it starts out as
being a normal the PK p qy l plasmid
that we've isolated from these organisms
and we see it in several places in its
there at least two places at the very
beginning where it looks essentially
normal or like it like the PK PQ oil but
then for the last four isolates when we
see it
it's there were combatant regions which
are marked by yellow and green and I'll
show you a diagram a little bit of how
that that works out in a multiple
alignment but these these differences
are these changes are are something that
we're not necessarily we're they're
gonna be looking for in this case
because this is diversification of the
plasma and maybe changing things like
host range or some of the abilities on
the plasma so the reason we got
interested in it is now if you look at
this alignment the first the first
plasmid at the top of the stacked
alignment is the is the normal sort of
pkp qil plasmid it has it has that - 66
designation because it has a couple of
snips relative to the reference and we
just want to call it something slightly
different and what you'll see is that as
you can you move down this alignment the
the second plasmid is the one that was
isolated from the e coli and you'll see
that that yellow region is different and
then the third one is one that was
isolated from one of those s t37 and and
I apologize I probably earlier if you're
not familiar with that terminology s T
stands for sequence type and so that's
just that's a way to designate different
strains of these organisms by some
keeping low so there's seven genes in
the sequence typing scheme for
Klebsiella pneumoniae st 258 and st 37
just tell you these are different
strains of element lending so anyways if
you look at that yellow region the right
end of it is is embedded in in a some
red genes and that actually is a
restriction modification system and it's
interesting because and that age the
restriction modification system is
interrupted such that the specificity
subunit is different between EK pql 66
and the the one that was isolated from
the e coli they're only about I think
about forty percent identical thirty to
forty percent identical at the amino
acid level so we might predict that this
restriction modification system between
the first and second plasmids whatever
different specificity and that might be
something that you would need in order
to expand your host range to a different
organism and in fact other labs dr.
Barry crys West lab for instance have
isolated pkp qil variants from E coli
before and at least in some cases on
this region this entire region is
deleted so this is the sort of thing we
don't necessarily want to see for an
important flies would like this that it
could be expanding its host range so
that was that was something that was
worth noting the other thing is that if
you look all the way down at the bottom
these were common origins actually match
up with a totally different plasmid that
that you can find on the reference
database is P P mk1
- C plasmid which which indicates so we
don't really know how these are
combination events occurred if they
occurred sequentially with the yellow
one happening first and then the green
one or if it was just a recombination
from an unknown donor like this p MK /
plasmid so like I said this is this is a
different case from what we saw with
patient 15s where the the plasma that
are recombining were essentially these
kind of accessory plasmids this is
actual modification to
a plaza they really care about because
it is carrying the Cape ECG so I in this
slide that the blue plasmid appears to
be undergoing some sort of gene loss or
sequence loss and eventually it
disappears completely in patient
sixteens isolates um actually when we
looked at this carefully we actually see
that this happens in three different
patients that are all at this sort of
terminal end of this transmission
diagram I mean you can see the three
examples there with the intact plasmid
at the top the the second plasmid is an
example where it's basically lost that
iron acquisition cluster and not much
else
and then in patients 15 and 16 it's lost
that whole region plus a chunk of the
the Trojans dissociated the genes that
are associated with plasma transmission
so we haven't really looked into
carefully into what exactly is going on
here and what we speculate is happening
is that this plasmid may be important
for for living in other or other sort of
niches non-human niches so either living
in the environment or competing with
organisms that are in other environments
and then once it's in a human host
perhaps and this for this really is
speculation it's not as necessary and so
you know as recombination events reduce
the size of this plasmid or eliminate it
completely
there's not really a Fitness cost to
that and so this is another example of a
of a plasmid that's that's doing
something interesting and it's happened
three independent times so we know that
patients 18 15 and 16 all started out
with a complete copy of this plasma so
the last thing I want to talk about for
this part of the story before I get
smoking sort of first set of conclusions
it is this sort of strange succession
issue that we have um so this is this is
patient 16 and we know that they started
out with an ST 258 sequence type of
Klebsiella pneumoniae but then through
the isolettes we sequenced and then
through pcr because these two sequence
types have different capsule or lobes or
assign as we have primers that we can
sink into those capsules and basically
do a screen
just to see which one it is it's not
perfect but it gives us some idea of
what organism is there if it's the st2
50s 2 through 7 and what we see is the
pattern that you sort of see here with
days across the bottom and I kind of
have it blurred out between the
transitions because we don't we don't
have a good idea of exactly when it
would transition I'm the one question
that I do get a lot is is about whether
or not so at some given time point
whether it's all s T 258 or all s 237
and I can tell you that in this case we
did do a couple of sort of almost
anecdotal they were small very
small-scale experiments just due to the
way that the samples were taken where we
played it and and looked at multiple
colonies on two different samples and
and ran PCRs and at least at the time
they were all the same organism so you
know it was all you know each we we did
PCR on 20 organism just all twenty
organisms for st 258 we don't know it
every time point whether this is the
case but it was it was a useful sort of
small space so some conclusions from
this first part are that patients can be
longitudinally colonized by carbapenem
ace producing organisms on very sort of
long timescales of years this has been
known before this isn't a novel finding
but it was something interesting for us
to sort of follow up over time more
important to our interest is that during
this time plasmas can move around and
plasmids can recombine this is not a
static process where the organism is
just sort of replicating and not doing
much of anything there there really are
sort of large scale things that could be
going on with the plasmids within this
organism including transmission two
completely different organisms and then
the sort of last point that I made is
that what what may appear to be a sort
of static colonization with a single
organism I mean the Klebsiella
pneumoniae organisms if you could
replace them out on carp enemies media
without doing sort of deeper molecular
tests they kind of may all look the same
it is possible that they could have
different morphologies but it's also
possible that you have a mixture of
organisms with the same more file
you wouldn't necessarily pick that up
with sort of routine clinical tests so
I'm going to switch gears a bit here and
tell a different story about about
Hospital plumbing and this is a this is
a study that that we did with the
clinical center again and the first
thing I want to kind of point out here
is that what we did is clinical Center
went through and collected samples from
a variety of environmental sources
including wastewater going out to the
manholes outside the hospital and the
externals of the hospital and taking
samples i'm sludge within pipes it
eventually kind of went to housekeeping
closets housekeeping equipment sink
drains things like that
somewhat similar to with the patients
these were these were not necessarily
exhaustively or systematically taken
where you know they were spaced out over
a certain period of time and exact
locations they were many times taken in
response to concerns about a particular
organism so we didn't always get to pick
or choose exactly what we know what
organisms or what what sort of timescale
we got to collect these on I can say
that you sort of if you look at the
total number of samples and the number
of samples with organisms that are carp
enemies carriers you can see that the
vast majority of them were negative so
that was actually a really good sign
something that we thought was positive
about this that most samples taken
especially from surfaces and things like
that in sink drains and traps and things
like that were negative for carp enemies
producing organisms the sort of and I
wouldn't say an exception to that
because it was a relatively smaller
number but wastewater that was taken
from inside of pipes in the ICU or from
manholes those there was only seven
samples in each of those classes but
they all had carpenters producing
organisms so while the hospital's
overall clean we we do know that there
is a reservoir these sort of organisms
that are in that is in things like
wastewater and in the end we ended up
sequencing about a hundred and eight
hundred and ten
organisms and we needed to compare those
and start to make some links between
them and between a variety of
patient-derived organisms that we had
sequence to already and we weren't gonna
be able to do that very readily with
sort of conventional alignment methods
so a lot of this work was done at least
initially with sort of camera counting
methods I'm going to talk a little bit
about that here this is this is actually
data from a slightly different set of
eye slits but it's illustrative of the
points I wanted to make and in most
cases we were comparing organisms to
each other using using like I said using
k-mers for doing whole genome
comparisons to ask how similar is
organism a organism B we used an
algorithm called mash that came out of
the Philip II lab that you can see in
the bottom right corner of your slide
there's a reference for that then what
mash does is it it's not an exhaust it
doesn't use all the k-mers in a so I
mean when I say Kaymer I mean that we
take the genome and break it up into
small small words of say 16 or 20 or 21
bases and then we're asking the question
about how many k-mers you know if you
take all the cameras from organism a and
all the cameras from organism B if you
were to do kind of a classic jacquard
comparison where you would be asking
what is the the overlap and k-mers over
the total union of all the cameras that
would kind of give you a jacquard what
they call a jacquard number and that
that goes towards one as the two
organisms become identical because
essentially the cameras that are shared
are the same as the cameras that are you
know between the combined organisms and
as the organisms get different that
number goes down it gets lower lower
Masha's using that same idea but it's
actually using it on so it's a min
hashing algorithm that uses a subset min
a subset of the Kaymer's i'm and so it's
very fast and you can use it to cluster
very large amounts of genomic data and
so that's the example that you see in
the middle the heat map is a selection
of a bunch of closed seal and ammonia
organism
our genomes that we have sequenced and
what you can see is that in this heat
map whiter the color is the more similar
they are the red or it is more different
they are and so you can definitely see
some some clustering there on the Box in
the upper corner is all s T 258 and then
even within that you can see clustering
of the organisms that came from the 2011
cluster because they're all essentially
identical so this was sort of the method
that we use to get an estimate for for
how closely related any pair of genomes
is and the method is quite accurate for
very closely related genomes it it
starts to tail off is thinking a little
more distant for each other the other
question that we were asking is a sort
of plasmid containment idea which is a
variant of what I showed on the other
the other Venn diagram and that's just
asking the question of if you take all
the k-mers and this is this is not using
mesh at the time this was a different
algorithm and ask the question of are
all of the cameras for a given plasmid
contained within a genome as a way to
say does this plasmid is this is this
genome containing this plasmid and we
needed to do it because we only
sequenced a fraction of our genomes on a
on a long read sequencer packed by
instruments so for many of them all we
had was fragment in genomes where the
genomes were in many pieces so what we
get out of this if you were to take I'll
go back for a second if you were to take
this heat map and just cut it off at
such a way that you were only gonna look
at the relationships that were above a
certain percent identity and then the
next slide is 99.9 you might be able to
draw relationships like this and so what
you'll see around the edge of this
diagram is different locations that we
would have got a nice little so though
all of the black eye slits are from
patients the red eye slits reform and
hole covers you can see as you go around
and that the icons are should be sort of
self-explanatory except for maybe the
fingerprint which is a high-touch
service and so we're not showing every
single link there are some sort of kind
of redundant and sort of self identity
links here that we're not buying on you
show but what you can see is these these
bands that
over from the patient's side of things
to some other surface and those are the
ones that were interested in those are
our issues we're an isolate in a patient
is 99.9 or greater than 99.9 percent
identical to an isolate that we got from
somewhere else in the environment and so
we took all of these data and we started
to look for certain sort of individual
stories and then also at this sort of
plasmids that we find in general and
while I mentioned earlier that we didn't
sequence all of our isolates with long
green sequencing we did try to sequence
sort of every every example of an
isolate that we found so if we found two
isolates that would appear to be very
similar to each other we only sequenced
one of them with with the PacBio
and so we got a pretty good catalog of
the plasmids that could be found in the
environment and in patients and from
that you can you can build a diagram
that looks something like this
and what you'll see is that the the
isolates are the plasmids that are in
the green circle are plasmids from
environmental isolates the plasmids that
are in the black circle or plasmids that
we found in patient isolates and then
the overlap in the middle are our
plasmids that we found in both patients
and the environment and then the the
fractional numbers that you see above
them are are the fraction that we found
in each group so for instance for the
ink and family of plasmids right in the
middle you see that there were 23 of
these found in the environmental and 7
found in patients so what you can see
here is that there's a quite a large
collection of plasmids that we only ever
really saw in in the environment and
there's not nearly as much overlap so
those plasmids have never been seen in
patients before and so one at least that
not ever in patients that that have been
sort of ascertaining we've got the
sample from and that was that was maybe
a little surprising to us because you
might assume that the source for all of
this sort of genetic diversity of
plasmids would be patient isolates being
washed down the sink but but that
doesn't appear to be the case and we
don't we don't have
a great explanation for this there's
there's a lot of factors that are going
to determine what organisms and what
plasmids get sort of fixed into these
sink environments or these pipe
environments and it could be that you
know these environments are selecting
for certain types of plasmids they're
just at very low frequencies in the
patient population there's a variety of
ways we could explain this but but the
point of this is that there's quite a
bit of plasmid diversity and that
plasmids that are inpatients are a
little bit different from plasmids that
are in your bag on the bottom right
corner you'll see a key that explains
kind of what those the dots are on
there's and and there's a lot of
different colors there but essentially
those are all the kpc genes there's
really only really only ever see keeping
co2 or kpc 3 which is alleles at the
same gene and then the outer ring is the
context so where what is the surrounding
sequence around the kpc gene and really
common is that the TM 4401
a and B transpose ons that are kind of
classically associated with a PC on the
MS -26 tmpa context that we talked about
a lot in our group that is it as a
common context that's found in the same
camp so one thing that we were
interested in is is again looking at
sort of plasmids of how they're related
to each other and something that's we
spotted was this this family of plasmids
that the oldest original one that we had
is this PE and TE 56 and so that's kind
of how we named the plasmid family but
you can see that there are examples of
it that are qc- those are the ones at
the top and you can see that there are
ones at the bottom that are KP some
positive and they differ by a variety of
different sort of translocations and
recombination events and again this is
this is not necessarily going to be
surprising to anybody who's plasma
biologists but we thought it was useful
to illustrate all of these different
variations all of these different things
that are kind of going on and the
diversity that's occurring and how
plasmids that you may kind of not pay
much attention to
because they don't have any genes you're
interested in you know it can eventually
become plasmids that are carrying a KPC
gene or some other antibiotic resistance
gene and so it's useful to have when
you're when you're doing these sorts of
experiments it is useful to to know all
the plasmids that are involved and sort
of to be able to see ones that may be
coming up as being interesting later on
and these were all these were all gotten
through through long read PacBio
sequences so we're we're fairly certain
about all of these little recombination
events or not sequencing or assembly
errors so I'm gonna end this this part
of the talk for my conclusions on two
different vignettes from this paper this
one's a fairly quick one and it was an
interesting one where there's a species
of bacteria called LeClair SIA it's a
type of nerve vector ECA and it's not
terribly commonly found it is it is an
opportunistic pathogen sometimes but it
was originally found in a surveillance
swab of from the hospital but then later
on turned up in patient B originally in
a perirectal swab and then later it was
isolated from from a different sample
and so we got interested in where this
Leclaire sia may have come from and if
it was associated with a source within
the hospital and there was a lot of
stuff that went into this but
essentially we ended up with the
Leclaire see is that all of the the
isolates that say LS nih are ones that
we sequence the rest are our reference
strains and so we sequenced eight of
them um you can see that they kind of
spread out around this tree it's not
it's not a terribly deeply or well
sequenced genus of bacteria but we have
two larger sort of three isolate
clusters a and B and then this C cluster
done at the bottom and what you can see
is that there's a a nice lip from a
house a piece of housekeeping equipment
is actually a mop bucket that clusters
very well with the two patient isolates
they're not identical
there are some snips between them um so
we don't believe that this is a direct
transmission but what it does point to
is it this piece of housekeeping from
this mop bucket is something that
traverses between housekeeping areas and
patient areas that's I mean that is the
nature of housekeeping equipment and so
it really alerted us to this idea that
there could be a reservoirs of sort of
diversity of these sort of diverse
organisms that could be being shuttled
around yeah a common pieces of when the
last the last little story i'ma talk
about is an interesting one that goes
back to that original slide that I had
with all of the different types of
plasmids that we isolated in in
immediately following the 2011 outbreak
I shed this sort of 20 diagrams and
different plasmids and this was a story
from that paper that at the time we
didn't have a good explanation for
basically at that time there was a
patient isolate this KP NIH 27 that had
five plasmids in it and then to ISIL
it's a citrobacter and enterobacter that
were found in sinks and in there there's
there's a longer version to this story
but essentially we know that we know
that this patient came in already
colonized with a KP C+ organism so we do
not think that this organism came from a
sink but this plasmid I should say it
came from a sink and went into a patient
isolate we're pretty sure it's the other
way around that the patient brought the
this main green plasmid backbone in with
them in an organism that that was no
they were going to be carrying and then
this plasmid eventually ended up in the
sink and we think it went in the order
that is shown on the screen so from
Klebsiella to set you back to such a
package of interim actor and we believe
that because of these on these
insertions so the first is that there's
a small expansion in the citrobacter
that's also found in the inner vector
with an additional insertion of an iron
uptake out and so we we knew that this
that this had happened that this plasma
transmission had happened one thing if
you if you're if you're sort of paying
attention is that the three plasmids in
the rightmost organism actually all
three of those plasmids have a KPC gene
so I'm using kind of the same coloring
throughout my slides and that these kind
of cyan and pink dots represent that the
K PCG I mean at the time we really had
no idea where these other two k pc
positive organisms came from
we couldn't speculate on but the NIH
Clinical Center actually has saves all
of the organisms that are isolated
especially kpc positive organisms in the
freezers and we went back and looked at
Summa some as part of a different
project some isolates predating the the
outbreak 2011 outbreak I mean
specifically we ISIL doubt an isolate
that was from a urine specimen and we
sequenced it again completely unrelated
to this but while we were doing all of
this mass clustering and looking for
links between isolates it fell out of
the data that that this particular
isolate from this this other kind of
unrelated patient clustered very well
with EC NIH - so that's this last
organism and so that was that was pretty
interesting and when we went and looked
really at the alignment of the
individual molecules so again this the
CC NIH - has a chromosome and then three
plasmids and that's that's shown in the
little box below and we can see very
very good coverage with very low numbers
of snips between the chromosomes so the
chromosome is 99% covered with only nine
snips and then two of the three plasmids
are also covered very well but that last
plasmid that PKA C 39 C is not curved
very well at all about 90% of it is
missing we can't we can't find an
alignment in patient Y which is this is
the kind of unrelated patient and
so really what that organism is is is
something like this it looks like the
ICI NIH - - that plasma and so what that
leads us to believe simply because of
the very very small number of snips and
because of patient trace data we
actually when we went back and looked it
turns out that patient Y and patient a
we're both in the same room at some
point in their stays they never
overlapped but patient Y was was in that
room from 2010 to 2011 and what we
believe happened is that the isolate
from them ended up in the sink somehow
and persisted through a time where there
was where was not occupied by patient Y
until a patient a also occupy in that
room at which point this plasma
transmission have been happened
generating EC NIH - the the organism
with three pleasance and we thought this
is actually pretty remarkable that an
organism could stick around in a drain
for awhile and then manage to pick up
additional plant an additional plasmid
and become kind of a composite organism
and again without without very very
accurate long read sequencing and being
really certain that these these really
only different by a handful of snips I
don't know that we would have been a
certain about this this conclusion as we
are so my conclusions from this part of
the talk are that hospital plumbing is a
reservoir for these carpenter and
producing bacteria per penny may start
producing bacteria this environment or
reservoir has a huge collection of
current pen amazing coding plasmids and
some of those overlapped with flies as
we see in patients that some of them do
not
and then we see evidence of plasmid
transmission and recombination between
patient eye slits and the environment
and really this was this is quite
eye-opening for us we thought it was
something that was was really
interesting and that people would find a
little bit surprising and maybe also not
tear
surprising at the same time you know
it's it's perhaps not surprising that
wastewater would contain sort of
antibiotic resistant organisms but see
these sort of connections between the
organisms between organisms and patients
was valuable so I just want to finish up
with my acknowledgments I'm actually an
associate investigator in dr. Julius and
Grey's lab that's the microbial genomics
section um so she's she's actually the
head of the lab and we couldn't have
done any of this work without her the
other two the two scientists that were
integral to all of this work are dr.
Karen Frank who is the microbiology head
at the time and dr. Tara Palmer who is
an epidemiologist and this really this
combination of genomics epidemiology and
microbiology was it was absolutely
critical to both of these studies we
needed we needed all of that information
and so folks from all three of these
labs were instrumental in getting all of
these papers and all this work done the
the picture there is a of other folks in
the lab and not shown in that picture as
Evans Nick and who really got all this
started with the original paper on the
2011 cluster my Slits and he's actually
now at a university mission so with that
I appreciate your attention and I'm
happy to take some questions Thank You
dr. Conlon for that informative
presentation we will now start the Q&A
portion of the webinar and we'll address
some of the most commonly asked
questions by our viewers if you have any
questions you'd like to ask please do so
now just click on the ask a question
drop-down box located on the far left to
your presentation window type your
question into the box that appears on
the screen and click the send button our
speaker will follow up with your
questions via email so let's get started
our first question is do you think it's
enough to sequence single isolates from
environments or excuse me or clinical
samples yeah so that's that's a
great question so you know I kind of
mentioned earlier than this lab we're
showing the sort of experiment where we
picked 20 20 colonies from a primary
sample ran a quick PCR on the MS showed
that they were all what we thought to be
the same sequence type so that was
telling us that in that sample there is
a reasonably good chance and it was
fairly homogeneous from that is't but
but in fact it's been shown in lots of
times by different labs on different
sort of model organisms that some some
infections do act as these sorts of
clouds of diversity where there's lots
of different variation and whatnot in
the organism and in some cases it really
is a clonal clonal situation so it's
somewhat depends on on what your system
is and what organisms you're working on
but we've actually taken a started doing
things like what we call plate swipes
where instead of sequencing a single
organism we'll we'll scrape all the
colonies off the plate and then do sort
of a more meta genomic sequencing and
then you're going to pile up the reads
on a reference genome and and look for
variation and things like that and so so
yeah so it's I think in many cases least
from a clinical standpoint you really
are limited by manpower of man or woman
power of how many isolates you can pick
off of a plate and analyze but if if you
do have the ability if you're planning
on a primary sample to scrape that
sample off a whole and sequence it I
think you get a valuable kind of
information from that I will say if you
do that also you know you're you're
trading off between having individual
pure isolates that you can then go back
and do things with unless you do that
kind of manual labor to kind of pick
individual colonies but it's definitely
something we're aware of and for some of
our studies we do a more meta genetic
and it looks like we have one more
question did you ever look at antibiotic
sensitive organisms Coco scuse me Co
cultured from the same samples as
resistant organisms yeah so so we don't
again and part of that is
because again because of the amount of
work it takes to culture the sample
sometimes there's many samples and
complaining on all these different types
of media every one of these requires a
person to sit down and do the plating
and do the picking in the evaluation you
know that said I think there there is
some value in doing sort of more of a
meta genomic or even microbiome kind of
approach where if you're interested in a
particular organism it may be worth
doing you know especially if you already
know the organism you already have a
genome for it it may be useful to do a
more meta genomic approach where you
sequence a shotgun sequence essentially
the whole sample as I kind of pointed
out with that the PE and t56 example if
you've if you've got plasmids in a
sample that that may be in sort of non
resistant organisms but are still
interesting or have for instance a broad
host range and would be good platforms
essentially for an antibiotic-resistant
to jump into and then start moving
around it would be really valuable to be
able to have that information about what
organisms are are around what organisms
are sort of inhabiting the same niche as
your organism that you care about I
would like to once again thank dr.
Conlon for his presentation I would also
like to thank laberd's for making
today's educational webcast possible
before we go I want to let everyone know
that today's webcast will be available
for on-demand viewing through December
of 2018 you will receive an email from
lab roots letting you know when this
webcast will be available for replay
please share that announcement with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
event that's all for now thank you for
joining us and we hope to see you again
soon goodbye